hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
monday monday uh may 10th
2021 what's going on how are you
how are you everybody i hope you're
doing good i'm doing [ __ ] great
i'm feeling great man i'm [ __ ] i i'm
flying on the simulator
every day doing ils
approaches having a great i can't
believe i [ __ ] know how to do it you
know i'm getting better at it i'm
holding my
altitude i'm tracking and intercepting
courses
um i'm having a great [ __ ] time i'm
actually kind of also
getting learning how to fly a plane
because they don't you have the
helicopter one so i just been doing the
plane one
and uh i'm starting to get it it's kind
of like you know these things are pretty
[ __ ] cool and they also haul ash
compared to a helicopter even the little
ones they [ __ ]
you know they're [ __ ] hauling ass um
seems like a lot of fun but
i sat in a plane uh a little cessna the
other day and god damn it you can't see
[ __ ] can't see a [ __ ] thing i mean
compared to a helicopter it's just
you know helicopter it's like you're on
a ferris wheel one of those little
buckets just
a glass bucket you can see everything
just something i enjoy
that [ __ ] i used to think they
couldn't see because of the the
the hood you know but i got in i was
like now there's all these [ __ ]
gauges and all of this trying to see
over all this i don't know i don't know
how they do it
i don't know how to do it i'm going to
stick with helicopters but i've been
having a great time with that uh getting
ready for my exam whenever the hell i
take that
um whenever my instructor signs me off
but i've been looking at my flash cards
for an hour in the morning
before everybody gets up and then you
know
yesterday was uh mother's day shout out
to all the ladies out there
you know who are moms you know only them
okay and i only want to hear from moms i
don't need [ __ ] women who don't have
kids telling me
all of this these [ __ ] broads out
there who aren't even moms and they
start wagging their finger it's like i
know what she did i was there
[ __ ] are you talking about you haven't
done anything what have you done with
your vagina huh
except have it peeking out under that
skirt could maybe get a goddamn drink
for free is that what you're doing
you're going to come over here and talk
to me
an old bald orange man i don't think so
sorry
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh i'll invent an argument i will i'll
do it in a second
so anyway um
i think my wife had a great mother's day
you know i was watching the kids all day
i went out i got her uh i went down i
tried to get her uh
what she has for for breakfast and we
showed up because it was mother's day
there was a [ __ ] line like two hours
long
two hours i asked the guy at the front
how long you wait here the guys that
took me two hours
that's like jesus christ so i text my
wife i'm like it's a two hour wait she
goes yeah [ __ ] that you know because my
wife's cool
so i went somewhere else just got our
breakfast burrito
um put my son down for a nap
played with my daughter did all of that
stuff and then my son woke up and i was
just
back and forth just running around
having an awesome time
and my wife just wanted to you know she
wanted to sleep
she wanted to chill out she wanted to
watch the office
and i did all that for the better part
of the day right until like five that
she gave my son a bath to put him to bed
because she's awesome
um so we'll see we'll see what happens
for father's day
you know because now i'm thinking like
oh [ __ ] do i get to like [ __ ]
sleep and uh do all of that [ __ ] yeah
you know because that'd be pretty
[ __ ] cool
uh i already know what i want to do
there's a town out here there's a town i
know where the hipsters go called
bedrock
twist twist um there's a town out here
in l.a
and they have this [ __ ] little area
that i call the triangle of death
that i want to go to on father's day
there's a barbecue
joint and right across the street
there's an old school
ice cream parlor and then when you come
back across the street
there's a [ __ ] cigar bar and i want
to go
bang bang boom
little barbecue [ __ ] root beer float
and then smoke a little [ __ ] shorty
right
or maybe a [ __ ] fat stick whatever
i'm feeling and then just
my first one since february
which i'm kind of afraid to do because i
don't know if i want to start that but
up again
um that's what i want to do i want to go
bing bang boom
you know i just want a [ __ ]
all i need is about three hours to make
that happen
you know to basically
live a life like you know i actually
have envy sometimes
when i look at like people when they
they just you know like how jackie
gleason lived his life i was talking to
somebody about that
where you just like you know the
doctor's like hey you know you better
ease off on the red meat and you're like
nah
i like steaks okay i'm here i'm eating
steaks
and then one day when the steaks catch
up with me and i [ __ ]
croak that's it there is something
to be said about that i respect that
as much as i respect you know
calorie counting staying in shape and
eating [ __ ] edamame
you know when you're 90. yeah that's
what i always did i outlived all of them
you know yes you did
so you got to respect both those ways of
living but uh there is something every
once in a while i'm not gonna lie to you
i'll watch my 600 pound life or
something like that
i go you know
the last 300 pounds was sad but those
first 300 was a good [ __ ] time
you you were having a [ __ ]
grand old time i'll tell you i ate like
my 600 pound life this [ __ ] uh
weekend
uh took my wife out to dinner oh by the
way i got i got to promote something
really quickly here i keep forgetting to
do this um
people do you know paul versi i'm
telling you right now he is one of the
best
[ __ ] comedians out there right now
that guy
[ __ ] murders murders and he's i've
been uh
i've been friends with him for about oh
jesus christ since 2005 16 years
all right love the kid to death and
we've been doing a podcast called
anything
better that's available on youtube apple
podcast spotify and wherever else
podcasts are available
please listen and subscribe to it um
those you unfamiliar with paul versi can
go back he was a guest
on my podcast i think the first time my
good lord
i don't know how many years ago we were
doing this run through canada
i asked him what he'd do with the time
machine and he said he'd go back to the
revolutionary war and he'd bring an uzi
with him
and single-handedly defeat the british
and then turn to george washington and
say you're welcome
all right that's the kind of person i'm
dealing with uh no he actually he's a
he's uh he's actually a very smart guy
who understands
how to live life you know he was talking
on the podcast the other day
about how he loves eating lunch by
himself
and just chilling out and watching the
breeze like moving the trees
you know and i just was thinking like
god i wish i could do that
i wish i could shut my brain off
and do that you know what i mean
everybody's running around
trying to go from one [ __ ] social
media platform to the next one
like a bunch of club kids back in the
day in the meat packing district you
know they just would they just go from
club to club to club
and it's all the same people but just
with a different background and every oh
this is the place
this is this is the cool place this is
where i'm gonna find happiness
you know or you could just sit there
eating a sandwich
enjoying nature i mean that's pretty uh
it's pretty [ __ ] deep
you know so um that's how he got the
name of the podcast
he would say [ __ ] like is there anything
better than chips with a sandwich
you know we still [ __ ] laugh like
dude you
anything yeah there's a lot things but
then now i get it
paul versi is here to remind us how to
be happy
and he's doing a podcast with one of the
most miserable [ __ ] ever myself oh
don't say that about yourself bill
um so anyway i went out to um
we went out to dinner in uh this italian
restaurant called
felix trattoria i hope i said that right
um and a long time ago it seems like
everything seems like a long time ago
anything before covid there's a chef out
there ethan funk
and uh there was this really cool
documentary on him called
funk f-u-n-k-e
um he's a master chef and it was about
him he was going
he went to italy and he was hanging out
with all these old women over there
that have been making pasta by hand
their whole life
and they actually have shapes that are
dying off like almost like a language
and he went over there to learn from
them because i guess a lot of the
younger italians because you just go buy
pasta and
you know i mean i'm not i'm not [ __ ]
on younger italian people i mean we used
to churn butter out here we don't do it
anymore right there's a lot of stuff we
used to do that we don't do anymore we
used to pump
oh no somebody used to pump your gas for
you what am i talking about um anyway
um so this whole documentary is about
the art of making pasta
by hand hand rolled pasta and then the
different shapes
and actually why they are the shapes
that they are
and um my wife and i watched that
documentary absolutely mesmerized
and i think was right before the
pandemic and we was like oh my god we
have to [ __ ] go
to that restaurant i have to taste what
that pasta tastes like
i mean if you're into food i'm telling
you
you got to watch that documentary so um
anyway we went there
i took her out there on saturday night
and had one of the great meals of my
of my life first of all this bread
i don't want to ruin the experience if
you're going to go there and stuff so i
want to say too much details but this
bread that came out
was like from another [ __ ] world
and we got these flourette things i
don't know what the heck some
i'm not the best remembering the names
of things
but it was just the appetizers were
incredible the pizza
was [ __ ] unbelievable one of the best
pizzas i've ever had
and we just got the marg did we get a
margarita we get i think we had some
some sort of
pepperoni on it or something um
and then we both got pasta dishes
and the pasta dish that i got was a
sausage dish
and the pasta that came with it almost
looked like those little
you know when reese's peanut butter cups
are like the minis it almost looked like
that but they didn't have the ridges
around the side
and i remember the documentary like
every pasta has a shape for a reason
and as i was mixing this thing up that
thing was scooping up all the flavors
and a little bit of
of the sausage and then as you're
getting like i'm hungry right now as you
put the fork in and everything you'd get
all the other stuff
that he had these [ __ ] tomatoes i
don't know where he got these little
tomatoes that were in there
that it was just heaven
and i i ate like a pig i just
[ __ ] i [ __ ] ordered everything i
ordered a pork shoulder
once i saw pasta it said a second dairy
whatever i'm like well i gotta go full
italian and order the whole thing
this pork shoulder was just out of this
world
and then like by the time by the time
dessert came
i was so stuffed like i was just like
we we can't we're gonna have to do it
next time
and um they're like you gotta you gotta
and then i don't know what happened all
of a sudden the kitchen just sent
out come on you gotta like classic
italians right [ __ ] you you're still
eating okay i don't care how full you
are
they had this dessert it was like a
pudding
a butterscotch pudding with this cream
on top and a little bit of salt in it
and i have not had butterscotch pudding
since when i was a kid and my mother
used to buy those swiss mists they had
the chocolate
and they had the butterscotch and first
i was all about the chocolate i was like
wait a minute
wait a minute this butterscotch is the
[ __ ] and this was the
gourmet version of that
and uh i will tell you this i would come
back to that restaurant
just for that so it's called felix
trattoria
f-e-l-i-x-t-r-a-t-o-r-r-i-a i'm sure i'm
pronouncing it wrong
but um oh my god
was that an amazing meal and my wife
ordered another pasta that was
uh it was a uh
i think it was just lemon and pepper and
it was just
i just kept saying i i can't eat anymore
and then another plate would come out
and i was just like i have to try that
and then i would eat it and then i would
just finish it off
and i'm recording on sunday that was
last night
i was so full i didn't eat till noon
today
and i wasn't feeling like i was fasting
or anything
i was just so full and satisfied
when i left there that i didn't even
give a [ __ ]
that we got stuck in this brutal traffic
there was some sort of accident you know
people always looking at their phones
hopefully everybody was all right
um and i i basically i spent the whole
weekend with my wife
and uh i only snapped one time and was
i only thought it was a little bit but
she said no no that's still
registered on the richter scale
um i i actually gave two drivers [ __ ]
but i was
funny about it we pulled in and we were
trying to go to some store we had to get
something from my mother-in-law for
mother's day
and as we pulled in this person you know
i was waiting clearly waiting for the
spot
somebody went around came around the
other way and took my spot just a total
[ __ ] little dirt bag move
and as she was sitting there you know
waiting to pull in i went by her and
both
our windows were down and as i went by i
just went
but i wanted it
right and the second i made the b sound
of butt
she jumped and i felt bad but i
committed to it i was like oh man i
actually stood she goes
you can have it it's like not good
so we pull up and now you know it's one
of those parking garages that for
whatever reason it has those numbers
like there's 117 spots this way
and you get there and you're still
fighting for a [ __ ] spot i don't know
where all those spots are
but you're still fighting for a spot so
i'm pulling in
and i see a spot opening up and there's
this [ __ ] jerk off
trying to get into a parking spot and
he's waiting and he can't do it he can't
do it then he sees another one opening
up and then he decides to wait for that
one while blocking the one
right and then and i had my window down
and it was perfect because it echoed the
second i could tell he was making that
decision
i just had the window done i just went
like oh my
god
[Music]
and i saw his head turn back and look at
me and he took his foot off the break
and he [ __ ] inched forward so i could
get
so i could get into the spot
so now i'm thinking like oh [ __ ] now
this guy's gonna get out of the car what
is [ __ ] gonna happen
but he actually stayed in the car he
think he thought i think he thought i
was a [ __ ] lunatic
which i am but i'm not like a violent
person or whatever but
um it worked i didn't and my wife
laughed both times when i did it she
like laughed almost like embarrassed so
um
i i just had a really great weekend with
my wife
she didn't see me snap i really have my
temper
uh has just like downgraded
i think it's downgraded finally after
all these years of being hurricane
bill i am now tropical storm
you know and i want to get all the way
down
to like you know you could fly a kite in
my anger
like you're on the beach just enjoying
yourself oh he she just
gets fussy sometimes um
and then i'll really let out all the
frustration don't worry guys i'll keep
the anger in my act but in my daily life
i i can't hand it like i actually found
humor
in something the other day where uh you
know we got a little splash about pool
in our backyard you know
do a cannonball in it you'd break your
tailbone not bragging
but we we do have a pool all right and
um
so like you know it's it's still like
cost like a [ __ ] zillion dollars
to heat the [ __ ] thing right so
uh i never heat it and i always just go
in
[ __ ] it you know but like you know
i got kids and [ __ ] i don't wanna i
don't wanna stick my kids in an ice cold
[ __ ] pool right
so i got this solar tap for the pool
which works unfucking
believable last summer it was like it
was working so well i was getting like
sick to my stomach like this is too hot
this is like jacuzzi hot
i'm trying to swim in this [ __ ] thing
right but
um i noticed you know i had it on this
year and it's not working
and i'm like what the [ __ ] and i went on
i went on the internet i'm like oh do i
have it
like wrong side down and it's like no
bubble side down this is what you want
to do so i was doing it
and it's just not working and then i i
read somewhere as i was washing it off
trying to clean the thing
it says keep it out of direct sunlight
when you're not using it because it will
damage it
and i'm just like it's a [ __ ] solar
panel
it's a solar pool cover like it lives in
the sun
you know what i mean and evidently you
can't have it out the whole [ __ ] time
or else it damages it so now the thing
is just this useless giant piece of
[ __ ] plastic
and i'm like what do i do with this
how do i dispose of this because i know
this [ __ ] thing if i throw it out
it's going to end up in the ocean
and it's going to be the size of a
little pool floating around and i don't
i just don't want that
to happen you know i'm actually really
excited that there's all of this stuff
out there
about there really there's a push back
on plastic and everything
like those guys liquid death the bottled
water that i drink now it's canned a big
looks like a giant tall boy like you're
drinking booze
like a beer or something um
i'm liking that these younger companies
are really taking a look at that
and i i really think that um
the next geniuses you know the
the the next albert einsteins or
whatever from this generation coming up
they're gonna solve this [ __ ] or they're
at least going to be working on it
and i think we're going to turn it
around just in the nick of time i have
to think that because i got kids
so freaking young so um and i think that
there's going to be a pushback from old
people
who are used to making money the old way
and i think eventually
i think i'm hoping eventually that it's
gonna
it's gonna stop because what in the [ __ ]
do you do with an old uh
solar pool cover what the [ __ ] do i do
with this thing i feel like i just gotta
stick it in a trash bag and just keep it
on my property
is like permanent trash cause i'm not
gonna throw that [ __ ] thing out
um cause i wouldn't want that thing just
floating around out there
it's one thing if they stick it in the
ground that's bad enough
i like to think the worms can get around
it but every time it ends up in the
[ __ ] oceans well that's way worse i
think
anyway um so
uh i have so much [ __ ] to talk about i
don't know where to get where to go here
um
one thing i do have to do is give a
shout out to uh
rest in peace tawny katane
um just an absolute
icon from my generation
uh the videos and all of that and i
actually had the opportunity i met her
one time
i didn't even know it was her and i'll
tell you this is this is
how amazing she was in the two seconds i
met her i did the improv
down in um irvine
and i guess she lived down in orange
county and she came out to the show
um i didn't know she was at the show and
in the end i was selling my dvds this is
how long ago that was
and as i was standing there like one of
the first people to come out
was this woman was with you know two two
women came out right
a little bit older than i am and uh
she came up and shook my hand just as
she was passing by she said hey great
show really funny
and kept and just kept walked out you
know just kept going right
and like she shook my hand it was like
[ __ ] electricity
i was just i was you know like what the
f what the [ __ ] was that
and she was just gone i remember seeing
a club on i go
i go who the hell was that is that like
the mayor down here that's like she's
got like
whatever that was has the [ __ ] it
factor like i've never seen
and he goes oh that's tawny katane
and i would have run away he goes from
all those white snake videos and all
that i go
oh my god that was her he goes yeah go
holy [ __ ]
i mean that was like uh i don't even
know where to put that
as far as like icons
uh uh meeting somebody of of like that
was like i have a few
things like that one time i was on jeff
garland
had a uh an improv
show called the combo platter or
something like
no that was the game he played in the
end combo platter there was four chairs
one person would stand up
start a story and then somebody could
stand up and interrupt
and then you just fed off of each other
it was a big improv game it was fun as
hell
we did it at ucb and jeff was
friends with the late great robin
williams and he came down that night and
he played the game with us and i
remember he was sitting next to me
and the usual spacing of two chairs next
to me
and as i was sitting there you know his
arm hair was touching my arm and i
remember
he had made so many [ __ ] jokes over
the years
on uh live aid about how hairy he was it
was like he was wearing like a [ __ ]
turtleneck sweater or something
and like when that arm hair touched my
arm i was like oh my god i grew up
not only watching this guy listening to
listen to him doing bits about this i
was like god damn he is a hairy son of a
gun
same thing and when his that happened i
remember just thinking like what the
like how the hell did i get here when my
paths crossed with this person but it's
the same he had the same
sort of like that just that
star power type of thing and uh
anyway but passing tawny contained
passing that is a huge one
for my generation um as you could see as
she was trending so
uh rest in peace um
really sad sad way too young 59 years
old jesus christ i'll be 59 i'm gonna be
53 in june
so that's a scary one not only sad but
scary to somebody
who's [ __ ] almost 53. um
all right what else can i talk about
here um i
saw uh you know i've been on this
mickey rourke going back watching all
the movies that made me love that guy
i watched uh pope at greenwich village
then i watched angel hat
and then uh over the weekend i watched
year of the dragon
uh directed by michael uh
i hope i say his name right chamino
i think that's how you say it the way
it's spelt and the way you say it
chamino i think is how you say it he
actually passed away
recently in the last couple years he was
the director of
um the deer hunter
with de niro and uh uh
christopher walken and all that stuff so
i was like i didn't and i didn't know
that
he directed this thing but he directed
um
interesting backstory on him i was
looking this up he directed the deer
hunter
and he won best director and best
picture
and then his follow-up heaven's gate um
was this huge box office bomb and
according to what i read
it stopped the whole director-driven
movie thing movies for a minute where
like for
before the revolution came
studios not only pick the movies to be
made or whatever
i mean i guess they still do they got a
green light up but they had
final final cut they edited the studio
edited the movie not the director
and then all those badass directors
which i should know more of their names
but i don't
the 60s came along and that's when you
got all those amazing amazing movies
um stanley kubrick probably being my
favorite of all of them
um i guess this movie
tanked so bad that they used it as an
excuse to kind of shut that down which i
don't really think so
because there was still those big time
directors when i was
you know growing up in the 80s um
you know and he had tarantino came
around in the early 90s so they they
were
like around but whatever i don't know i
don't know enough about it but anyway
and then i heard what years later now
people go back and they watch heaven's
gate they go that's actually a good
movie
um just sometimes when a movie has a big
budget and this buzz starts going that's
not going to be good i think you're
[ __ ] before it even comes out back
then you were
uh there's a lot of movies like that
were you watching like what are they
talking this movie is actually a good
movie i'm not saying
it could have made all this money back
but it's it's not as bad as they're
saying it is
um so anyway um this guy michael uh
chimino
also made this movie year of the dragon
with mickey rook
and uh as far as violence goes i give it
a 10
great gun sound uh great gun fights in
it and [ __ ] it's got the classic 80s
where a car
you know goes into it there's one thing
this guy gets
shot through the back window they cut to
his face it blows his brains out
he's driving a late 70s [ __ ] camaro
it goes into a brick wall and just
[ __ ] explodes like did did
was this thing modified where he put
like
is the engine in the back and they put
the gas station a gas station a
gas tank in the front it's so ridiculous
how much it blows up
but um aside from mickey rook the two
performances that were
amazing was uh john lone who played the
uh the uh
so i guess you would say the uh the
anti-hero i don't know how this
i don't know how you say all this [ __ ]
he was the head of the the triad or
whatever
he was like a mafioso dude in chinatown
and uh
he was [ __ ] amazing in it and his
character was badass like the young guy
who doesn't want to do it the way the
older guys are doing it and he wants to
move faster than they're moving
um and then but the performance of the
movie
was this woman uh caroline cava i'm
hoping i'm saying that right
she is [ __ ] amazing i thought she
stole the movie
absolutely stole the movie her
performance in that thing
uh basically when her her marriage is on
the rocks with mickey rourke
that scene at all of her scenes but that
scene i mean i
i can't believe uh she didn't get some
sort of
supporting role nomination for that so
shout out to her
um i looked her up she's still doing it
she's teaching
people how to act if you get an
opportunity to get taught by her man
my god if she was that good that long
ago i can't imagine all the knowledge
she's had since then so
uh really enjoyed that movie and then i
watched a dateline with my wife who
really has to come on here and start
talking about these things
she's going to be she's making me go to
bed watching these movies about these
[ __ ] horrible people most of them are
guys
and um i went to bed last night and i
had i had a dream that a friend of mine
got
murdered so i had to call the person
today
to make sure they were all right but i
didn't tell them that that's why i
called
because i didn't want them to think a
piano was going to fall on their [ __ ]
head
so anyways i was watching this one
where once again it's it's a married
couple they look happy as hell
they got the sweaters on the family
photos they got three beautiful kids
everything's going great and then i
don't know what happened all of a sudden
the marriage starts going south
and it kind of sounded like he was a bit
of a bum right like he didn't want to
work
like he had a part-time job and his wife
had three jobs okay
he was a mr mom he worked part-time he
talked her into buying some huge
you know them but really her buying in a
hugely
expensive house and i'm sitting there
watching this scenario going
gee that's that scenario sounds really
familiar it's just
flipped this time it's usually the
woman's working part time in these i'm
not saying all women everybody [ __ ]
relax
in this scenario like women do that all
the [ __ ] time
you know you know they work their little
15 hours a week
we need a bigger house i need more space
and then they get you to buy the [ __ ]
thing you're working three [ __ ] jobs
blah blah blah and then they drop the
[ __ ] divorce papers on you
right and then you know they're working
they're not making nearly as much money
as you are
so you're gonna pay child support well
this [ __ ] dirty bastard
he tried to make the court system work
for him this [ __ ]
he worked part-time his wife's slaving
away
three [ __ ] jobs she buys an expensive
[ __ ] house
okay and then he slaps her with divorce
papers
while she's at work teaching in front of
the kids for maximum pain
really sadistic right and
uh then he goes to court and he he tries
to pull the check move like i only work
15 hours a week and i'm used to a
certain lifestyle and i want the kids
and i want her to pay for this big
expensive house
you know what the judge said
he said hey [ __ ] you buddy get a job you
bum
not only do you have to go out and get a
job she's staying in the house
she's getting the kids and you're gonna
[ __ ] pay for it
so he was living all right and i gotta
tell you something as much as a piece of
[ __ ] as this guy was
i gotta be honest with you he had a case
he had a case because the law stated
that they would go back
three years and they would look at the
income of both people
and determine you know whoever was
making more had to pay the other one
child support right
or uh not child support uh what do they
call it uh alimony
child support right so this guy
said oh is that how the games played and
he set himself up
and this judge circumnavigated as far as
i can tell without a law degree and even
knowing what [ __ ] state they were in
circumnavigated the [ __ ] laws and
said no
because you're a man this ain't gonna
work that way ain't going out that way
okay
and this guy got so [ __ ] mad
i mean he was obviously already a a a
psycho
he snapped and he [ __ ] killed his
wife
in a brutal brut he stabbed her like
over
50 [ __ ] times i mean just one of the
most
horrific [ __ ] things ever right
um but he said he was sleeping on his
mother's couch
all right and she made a statement that
she heard the sound of the door opening
and closing at around three in the
morning
but then when they were gonna finger him
for the murder
uh because they couldn't find a weapon
or anything he he
she recanted that statement like you
know i don't i
don't remember i can't [ __ ] think
right now right
so she covered for him and this
[ __ ]
didn't go to jail for like 14 years
right
but his hell was not over
okay because he painted himself out she
nags and blah blah i love that [ __ ] she
nags well then [ __ ] divorce her
[ __ ] idiot right so all of her
friends
were like these bible belt people and
they were like sending him scripture
saying that he was gonna go to hell and
the truth is the way to repent just
doing this [ __ ] so he had to move away
and he essentially got away with it but
then the guy
[ __ ] that he is goes out hunting
with his brother and he has a couple of
they said he had a couple of beers
right i don't know if these were bud
talls or what he had two beers
and then he confesses the whole thing to
his brother
they're sitting on a bridge he's like
duh you know remember uh your
sister-in-law
and the guy's like yeah and he's like
yeah
he goes he opened the bag and showed the
murder weapon
he goes this is how i finalize the
divorce
and then takes the [ __ ] knife and
throws it
in a creek not even in a river i don't
know how deep a [ __ ] creek is but
it's definitely not a real he throws it
in the [ __ ] river he tells his
brother
throws it in the [ __ ] river so then
his brother goes home and he goes
ma hey my dog
she's like i'm upstairs and he comes up
he goes
hey ma you remember
you know so-and-so's first wife
she was like yeah he's like yeah well
you know [ __ ] mikey said he killed
her
and she goes oh jesus christ could you
do me a favor
could you not tell anybody until i'm
dead i swear to god this is a true story
i'm just sitting there watching this
[ __ ] going
this is what my wife watches
before you go to bed and i am just
sitting there
thinking of oh by the way the wife
that the guy murdered was laying in bed
week because she donated a kidney
to somebody she worked with and he
waited until she was [ __ ] weak
and and and he just came and she knew
that he was gonna [ __ ] do it
and he i just can't imagine i'm sitting
there thinking about the horror that she
went through
i'm thinking about that mother finding
out that her son when she kind of knew
it anyway
finally realizing that she raised a
[ __ ] murderer
and that she on her death bed has to sit
there
you know she's got that love for her son
that she can't [ __ ] turn him in
but knowing she should have and then
it's like now do i go to like half hell
because i didn't do
and i'm sitting there going through the
emotion of all this right before i go to
bed
i don't know why my wife when i'm
literally sitting look at my wife it's
like
is she trying to [ __ ] figure out how
to do the perfect murder i mean i know
i'm difficult to work with but this is
making me [ __ ] nervous right
so anyway these cops
[ __ ] amazing they go and the scuba
divers they dragged this river
three [ __ ] times they're about ready
to give up and all of a sudden it snags
on something and they pulled up that
knife i mean one of the i mean this is
years later they found this [ __ ]
thing
um and then they went down
and they [ __ ] arrested the guy and
the cop took a picture
and sent it to like the woman's best
friend the deceased woman's best friend
said look who i got in the back of my
cruiser
so i mean it's like all right so it has
like a happy ending but i still went and
then they'd like
you know they got one of the kids on
there who has to find out that her dad
murdered her mom it was just
[ __ ] brutal
and i'm watching this whole [ __ ]
thing right before i go to bed
and then the comedian me is also like
the brains going like you know what's
[ __ ] up about that is like
if they did that if they did in court to
a woman what they did to that guy
she in some way would have been able to
use that as part of like you know i
wouldn't have snapped if he treated me
equally
and would have somehow figured out only
getting 15 years
so here's the thing i've learned that a
lot of my anger comes from the fact
that i don't feel like anybody's going
to listen to me because i came from the
sit down and shut the [ __ ] up
generation here's a key let yourself in
and out
you know so um
i i have since learned that all like
most of the times if i just say
hey you know what i think i'm going to
tell
although i don't know i i kind of like
it i can't even say that i've actually
gotten into the real housewives i
finally just
sat and watched him with her and i kind
of got into the soap opera of it so now
i actually watch the [ __ ]
but i think i'm gonna tell her uh and
just be like listen
not for nothing i had a dream last night
that one of my good friends got murdered
and i woke up feeling like i had to call
them because all of a sudden i felt like
that short lady in poltergeist like i
knew something was gonna happen
uh can we tone down the [ __ ] uh
and plus i don't like going to bed
watching a married couple
with their beautiful family photo and
then seeing one killed another and this
is what we're watching and then we're
gonna go to bed
and i gotta [ __ ] go to sleep with one
eye open being like why the [ __ ] does
she like watching this [ __ ] so much
i actually asked her because i was like
snl did a whole sketch on this i guess
that
i mean i i guess maybe predominantly the
viewers are women i have no idea but
my wife actually broke it down really in
a cool way she goes well you know
as a woman you got to worry that
something violent is going to happen to
you
so i watch those things because i try
and think what i would have done
to prevent it and i was like you know
what
that's a [ __ ] great reason to watch
this [ __ ]
um having said that i i don't want to
watch it
so um anyway that was my [ __ ] weekend
uh let's let's let's read a little
advertising here for the uh oh i got a
couple here
uh roman okay hey guys we got big news
your favorite men's
healthcare brand roman is now available
at walmart congratulations to them they
got a big deal there
roman's non-prescription products have
got you covered with everything from
sexual health
to everyday health uh your well-being is
important and taking care of it should
be simple
so now you can add to the car add to
cart
irl i don't know what that means all you
kids probably know what that means
roman now available at walmart uh we're
in your area
let's go take care of it sexual health
roman condoms
are now are new and exclusive to walmart
you won't find them anywhere else
designed ultra thin in uh lubricated for
pleasure
and fda cleared because safe is sexy
over-the-counter otc medication roman
swipes are an easy discreet way to delay
ejaculation if you're busting enough too
quick you know you put that on
numbs it just enough all of a sudden
yellow mini porn star right there
probably shouldn't have said many when i
was talking about the dick region
and increased sexual stamina
they're fast acting and your partner
will enjoy them too no passed along
desensitation
if uh you use as intended
dietary supplements doctor formulated
with 23
nutrients roman daily is a multivitamin
that is optimized with ingredients to
support
men's health and over over overall
well-being i love that people finally
figured out that guys need to be healthy
too this is like
this taking care of everything roman's
team of in-house doctors create this
unique high quality supplement to target
nutrition gaps in men with
scientifically backed ingredients
ingredients and dosages remember
supplements are not a replacement for a
healthy diet exercise and good sleep
you've still got to eat your greens and
get your steps in
yeah god knows that uh since roman daily
is a dietary supplement and not a drug
any mention
of benefits of products cannot allude to
treating diagnosing curing
or preventing a disease or condition
benefits
or if uh efficacy out of
e-f-f-i-c-a-c-y statements
should be kept to general maintenance of
oh this is what i'm supposed to be
saying
oh this is like tips for me don't say it
[ __ ] cures cancer i wouldn't
uh visit your local walmart store today
and check out roman's
uh romans line of men's healthcare
products that's
roman men's healthcare products now at
walmart
all right oh look at this one here hey
guys spring is here
you gotta take care of your lawn that's
where sunday
sunday sunday sunday sunday sunday comes
in
take care of your lawn this year be the
greenest on the block with sunday lawn
care
dude you can't have a brown lawn you
have a brown lawn people think you're
going broke people start driving by
whisper they're going to lose the house
i think they're having problems when was
the last time you saw
this reminds me of a dateline episode
just keep it green
if you know what i mean oh it rhymes so
maybe you'll do it sunday is more than
just a lawn care
product it is a custom lawn care plan
with a variety of ways
to help you grow a beautiful lawn
control weeds and remove pests
they take out all of the guesswork and
unwanted chemicals
so you can grow a beautiful lawn that's
better for people pets and planet
and the planet if you tried sunday
add-ons like weed control
seeds or pest control share your
experience were they
easy to use and what were the results
well i live in a desert so i don't
really have a lawn
uh but my buddy paul verzi used them
said it works great
uh is is this your first time getting
serious about law encore
lawn care no i i don't have a lawn
sunday
makes taking care of your lawn easier
than ever
you can go to sunday.com put in your
home address and their free lawn address
analysis tool took care of the rest all
in just seconds sunday uses
soil and climate data to create a
tailored
nutrient plan so you get all the stuff
your lawn
needs and nothing it doesn't sunday is
made with ingredients that you can
actually pronounce like seaweed
iron molasses so you can grow a better
so you can grow better and feel better
about it
look at that this is like all natural
way to grow your lawn you won't be
killing other
animals little rodents that get eaten by
bigger animals the next thing you know
the mountain lion in your neighborhood
is sick
uh sunday explains exactly what you get
and why and everything is waiting at
your door
when you need it all you have to do is
attach the ready-to-use
pouch to a garden hose and spray i mean
it doesn't get any easier than that
lawn care used to take up your whole day
now it takes less than 15 minutes best
of all this stuff really works
and your grass will look better than
ever let's uh let sunday take the
guesswork out of growing a greener more
beautiful lawn this spring
visit getsunday.com to get 20
off your first custom lawn plan and
check at checkout
that's 20 off your first custom plan and
get
sun at get sunday getsunday.com
i mean that'll make your wife happy
right nice green [ __ ] lawn
you're out there you know she thinks
you're slaving away you what'd you do
huh
did a little porn star action sprayed
all over it you walked in the house sat
down and watched the end of the knicks
game
[ __ ] knicks i'm not losing watch my
celtics i watched the third quarter
of the heat beating up on us but i guess
we came back i'll tell you how [ __ ]
amazing
the talent is in the nba for some reason
they want to stick it on two teams
but like that kid duncan robinson
the level of that how good a shooter
that guy
is like there's so many guys that are
like borderline
larry bird good and they're like i know
that guy's known but i mean
he if he was that good in the [ __ ]
80s
like he'd be on the cover of a cereal
box
he'd be the best guy on the [ __ ] team
basically
and he hasn't they got jimmy butler all
right gen z is [ __ ]
says somebody i was actually
complimenting that generation after uh
the millennials i thought that uh the
millennials
you know they got a lot of [ __ ] dumped
on them and i i don't know that they
even got to enjoy
uh being young with all these [ __ ]
older people after they went around and
did all the [ __ ] that they
did i don't know what they did they over
they babied them i have no idea uh gen z
is [ __ ] or maybe it's because the uh
the way
baby boomers were raised did baby
boomers have millennials
i think they did as did my generation
but i just waited so [ __ ] long
gen z is [ __ ] hello billy the bar bag
burr um i was listening to your most
recent podcast and the guy that i was
talking
about gen z what okay i was listening to
your most recent podcast and the guy
that was talking about gen z being a
bunch of [ __ ]
um i don't know they seem pretty cool to
me
i'm also a gen c [ __ ] and beginning to
see this
molly coddling of stupid you spelled
stupid wrong
and over sensitive [ __ ] more often
maybe you spelt it wrong
on purpose i am from scotland so our
cultures are a bit different
however i see my fellow gen z compadres
on twitter
all snowballing onto this bandwagon of
being dimwitted [ __ ]
and expressing ridiculous opinions well
i just
that's that's a symptom of social media
i see you see older people you want to
see older people do it go on facebook
they're doing the same thing
that's just i don't know what it is
i'm sure that scientists are doing a
study on the effect
of um social media on your your own
mental health your ego and all of that
[ __ ]
so i wouldn't put that all in just gen z
people but anyways
what's becoming popular among these
[ __ ] in the past two three years
is being a cool hipster anti-capitalist
commie
with no good patter whatsoever uh
i am in no way saying that the
capitalist countries we live in
are a utopia however i'd have to say
after just knowing the history of
communism
it's probably not the best idea to start
a [ __ ] revolution anytime
soon well do you really think they're
going to
they're not they're just taking on a
personality you know i was the [ __ ]
uh well not until i got older but i was
like the conspiracy theory guy
reading behold the pale horse and all
that [ __ ]
uh these [ __ ] spastics are now also
oh
spastics coming from uh scotland that's
an edgy word
you're not supposed to say that over
there i thought are now also doing what
they proclaim
the big dad capitalist oppressor has
been doing to the people
for the past century by shouting down
any opposing opinion
and labeling them as racist sexist and
the rest of it
in the name of free speech and freedom
uh i nice one you bunch of fannies i
wish i could say that a scottish accent
um i hate to tell you this dude you're
putting this on a generation there's
liberals my age that are doing the same
thing
um they are
unbelievable liberal they are
unbelievably liberal as long as you
you see the world exactly the way they
do and if you don't they try to figure
out a way
to take away your career um anyway i'm
not what you would call right wing or
left wing in any way because politicians
are a bunch of
arseholes and i'd rather not side with
any of the [ __ ]
anyway sorry if this was a bit long i
just wanted to give my two cents on the
matter hope
you're going well you're doing well and
can come to
scotland glasgow for some stand-up as
soon as this lockdown bullshit's over
uh kind regards and go [ __ ] yourself
yeah um listen
i i know that that that [ __ ] that you're
talking about is a new
breed of [ __ ] but i want you to know
that that transcends generations
that that person is uh
is in the park you know where the
parents are watching their kids there's
that person
they're kind of everywhere the social
justice warrior
um who i really believe most of what
they do
is not actually for people of color it's
so they can talk about it amongst their
liberal white friends later to say the
amazingly brave thing that they did
the tweet that they put out or the thing
that they said that they didn't tolerate
like that that's how deep they go into
actually solving
i guess all the racism and the power
structure is they um
they take a firm stand on things on
social media and then they get back to
their white lives
um all right i don't know how to say
this word
kombucha a nice alternative to boozing
hey bill
uh put you through that [ __ ] space
wall burr oh nice
a little efforts for family and
mandalorian reference
uh greetings from a fellow [ __ ]
ginger
i love when a fellow redhead writes in
uh nice work
with the sobriety i wanted to share
something that helped me cut down on the
booze it's called
kombucha hope you haven't heard of this
i've heard it in a writer's room used as
a reference but i thought it was a
coffee or something
if you if you have feel free to toss
this email in the trash
it's fermented tea and it's super
healthy
it has living bacteria in it so it's
great for your gut health
think yogurt it's a solid alternative to
beer
i'm old enough that i would try this i
drink it when i'm gambling i'm gaming
sorry with my buddies
and don't want to drink alcohol it's got
the right fizz
and gaseousness so it makes me feel like
i'm drinking something with some
substance
oh by the way at that restaurant too i
ordered an orange soda that they made
like homemade it was [ __ ]
unbelievable
um anyway it does have super low alcohol
.25 or minus five percent as a
as a byproduct of the bacteria but you
don't feel it at all all right
you don't have to you'd have to drink
ten to to equate
one miller light there's a ton of
flavors i like
the honey if you get some swirl it don't
shake it
uh the thing will erupt like a freshman
on prom night
hey nice run that's a that's a decent
joke
i figure it might be uh of some use to
you
cheers and congrats on the wonderful
family thanks for all the laughs and
insight hearing you acknowledge and work
on your anger
has been a big help for me to do the
same cheers well that's nice
i hope everybody does that that's why
i'm not into cancelled culture
i've made every [ __ ] mistake he can
make and i think that
like as long as you're trying to be as
long as you look back on yourself five
years ago and be like what the [ __ ] was
i thinking why did i say that why did i
do that
if you have some sort of shame looking
back at yourself five years i feel like
you're growing as a person
but this whole [ __ ] thing going back
into somebody's past and being like
what is this about it's about being a
human being and being wrong in that
moment
is that one moment what i am because
i've done some good things why can't you
just look at the one good thing i did
seven years ago and then aha that's
that's who he is
give him a nobel peace prize i'm all of
it
the good the bad and the ugly uh
socialism
hi bill you redheaded [ __ ]
i really appreciate the bluntness of
that how how are you
um last week you mentioned uh you don't
know
why people demonize socialism
um i was really taken aback at that
statement oh jesus christ
every country that has tried socialism
has failed
and it's responsible for tens of
millions of deaths all right so would
you say capitalism is working
and it is not uh you know when like what
is it like 99
of the wealth isn't like [ __ ] two
percent of the people's hands
all of these tent cities you're telling
me this is working you don't think
capitalism is responsible for tens of
millions of deaths
um anyway russia germany china cuba
and most recently venezuela have tried
or right now
are socialist countries as far as i know
whatever cuba was trying to do
we prevented them from doing with a
[ __ ] embargo or whatever the hell we
did
we've been [ __ ] with them for 60
years
so i think you're looking at like you
know
like what a lot of people do is you look
at your own country
through rose-colored glasses the same
way you look at your own sports team
like oh my team doesn't cheat
but your team does um i'll be honest
with you i don't think any form of
government
works because there's human beings
running it and there
is inherently going to be backdoor deals
and people
you know just with are just going to
have the in
and they're going to pay off politicians
and all of that okay um
i do what i do like about this here is
that you have the opportunity to move up
you're not stuck with where you're at
but i mean
you're you're really you're really sort
of looking the other way with what
capitalism has done to other countries
um all the sweatshop labor
all the wars we've fought in over air
quote freedom where
most of it is about you know natural
resources
all of these [ __ ] countries where
we've gone in and
you know stuck in heads of the
government that are going to do what we
want to do so we can
[ __ ] take advantage of them like i
mean to sit there and look at capitalism
like like it's
you know i don't know dude but once
again i don't even think you can blame
capitalism on that i think you just can
blame
sociopathic people that both
crave and ascend to positions of power
um all right i took off my bergen stocks
i'm gonna read the rest of this here
okay socialism
all starts the same way create a
boogeyman like corporations
the rich or a race oh yeah we've never
done that in
this country we've never created a
boogie man
yeah there's never i mean jesus christ
buddy blame them for all your problems
yeah we never did that the leaders then
promised to fix
all the problems oh boy slowly the
government starts to control every
aspect
of your life why does this sound so
familiar
promise that every aren't they like
recording all our phone conversations
now
and we're slowly on our way to getting
microchipped uh promise that everybody
will have the same
equity and outcome this creates
mediocrity
loss of the middle class loss of the
middle class where have i seen that
before
uh of innovation uh punisher you know
corporations are buying houses now
they're just buying them up so they can
[ __ ] airbnb like literally the
american dream buying a house they're
gonna take that away in this country
uh that reduces the tax money coming out
into the government buddy i can't
[ __ ] read all of this horseshit
this is everything that we're doing too
capitalism okay i'll get to the end here
capitalism now you know what let's just
read all of this because it's [ __ ]
hilarious that he's acting like none of
this is happening in this country
um and you know what's funny about
people you don't like it get the [ __ ]
out of here this is my favorite
thing ever yeah you can look at your
sports team
and be like what the [ __ ] is this coach
doing and then nobody goes like you
don't want
a [ __ ] roof for somebody else
no i'm criticizing it because i love it
and i want it to win uh
anyways this creates mediocrity uh
loss of the middle class loss of
innovation
punish the rich which eventually leads
to them leaving the country
oh yeah that hasn't happened that hasn't
yeah the rich haven't like you know
their money leaves the country and then
comes back in the form of an
interest-free loan that is then forgiven
jesus buddy come on uh that reduces tax
money coming into the government
and loss of jobs because the richest
people usually employ the most
of the population oh boy disarm the
citizens so that they can't
cannot revolt control the media like
promoting the government
control the media there's two guys that
own the media ted turner
and [ __ ] uh that other guy there the
guy from fox news
um that's why we're hatfields and mccoys
right now
disarm the citizens so they cannot
revolt control the media like promoting
the government agenda with propaganda
then censorship of all their other ideas
yeah creating areas where you can only
protest which are down and around the
corner
away from the uh the [ __ ] media yeah
okay
eventually all rights are taken away the
centers journalists and politicians
oppositions are jailed or executed
eventually the leaders will be
uh become exactly what they originally
campaigned against
jesus christ buddy i i've forgotten what
your
he goes there's much more to it on an
economic level but as a fellow [ __ ]
it's too complicated for me to
understand all right
i am also a fellow [ __ ] but dude all of
that [ __ ] has happened
if you look at all the rights and
everything that you have lost
in the last [ __ ] 20 years
um i don't even know i don't even begin
in creating a boogeyman and racism
genocide every week all of that [ __ ]
we've done all of that
you know when i was a kid there was
rules on media ownership no one person
could own any seven
it was rules of seven no one person can
own seven radio stations newspapers tv
stations blah blah blah
in in one market because they knew if
you control if you
owned all of that if you control the
media you control thought and yet
they've let ted turner in that [ __ ]
uh
uh i want to say ralph nader rupert
murdoch
do exactly that and present
cnn and fox news have the [ __ ] balls
to present the people that are on tv as
journalists and then also acting as
though you're watching news you're not
you're watching propaganda
okay so there you go all right
okay transgender fan hey all right look
at me crossing over here
hey billy i've been listening to uh the
podcast since i was 16 i'm 22 now and
have enjoyed every episode especially
during quarantine i'm a violinist
sculptor and a trans man look at you
uh definition in the next paragraph
thank you and have been
wanting to write in for a while after
hearing you read the letter a fan sent
in
about his trans friends attending his
wedding i thought now would be the time
oh beautiful all right let me do the
recap
so this guy was um
getting married and not one but two of
his friends
that he was gonna have big groomsmen
either had transitioned or were in the
process of transitioning
and he was like am i an [ __ ] if i
don't want him to wear a dress
okay that was the question so me knowing
nothing about the subject that didn't
stop me from answering it that's in the
i believe the previous or two
episodes ago um all right so now we're
gonna actually hear from somebody
uh living the life here first off i do
want to clear clarify
that by trans man i mean i transitioned
from
female to male
oh [ __ ] okay i didn't get that
i thought trans man meant you went the
other way
okay in in instrument rating that would
be reverse sensing
uh on a vor uh for all you pilots out
there in short
i'm a he and your response to the fan
that wrote in you said that
transitioning seems like a massive
emotional process
and you're exactly right hey look at me
look at me not bad for a
fifth white male uh when i describe the
experience which i do openly
to create a dialogue for people who are
generally curious
i often say that transitioning is not an
option but more so the only option from
for most people like me
let me ask you this before you totally
committed was there any doubt like okay
i hope because i mean i hope i'm doing
the right i hope i'm getting this right
because i can't tell you how many times
i've misread my feelings i mean
it but the stakes were not that high
that's like [ __ ]
you're going all in with the chips so to
speak uh anyway he goes imagine you wake
up one day with boobs
and are ha and are expected to wear
heels
after the novelty of having of having 24
7 access to tits
wears off it [ __ ] sucks let me read
this again imagine you wake up one day
with boobs
and are expected to wear heels all right
now wait a minute i thought you
transitioned
from a woman to a man i mean i mean i
transitioned from
female to male okay says imagine you
wait oh maybe
she's uh he's putting me in this i don't
know
imagine you wake up one day with boobs
and are have and are expected to wear
heels after
the novelty of having 24 7 access to
tits wears off
it [ __ ] sucks nobody chooses to go
through all of that trouble of being
a lot alienated from friends and family
members on a whim
well there you go you just answered my
question for me if i wanted to have a
future
post-high school i had to make this step
and i have avoided a lot of further
mental
dissonance dissonance thanks to the
scientists and surgeons who advocated
for trans medicine and yes i will always
trust the opinions of a scientist over a
politician
fair enough as the wedding scenario goes
i can guarantee his transgrooms
were just as conflicted as him i also
came out right before a relative's
wedding and was given an ultimatum of
you either lie about your identity if
you want to remain a part of this family
or you won't be welcomed back into our
lives and it's just
[ __ ] can you imagine your family
saying that to you i ended up playing
violin at their ceremony for free and
never getting invited to another family
reunion
wow that is really [ __ ] sad i'm sorry
that happened to you
uh hopefully uh jesus in the near future
that doesn't happen how do you disown a
[ __ ]
your own kid i i don't get that
i don't get that i mean i draw the line
of you know hearing my kid leave
and then getting charged with at night
and covering for a murder
i mean there are lines um
yeah you do some dateline [ __ ] you know
i mean you're kind of out or you know
but i'd still visit you when you went to
jail and i would be like where did i
[ __ ] up that made you do something like
that
um anyway personally if i were asked to
be a bridesmaid before coming out as a
guy
i would i would have stepped down
because
i don't want to be the one guy in a
traditional
traditionally female role i'm betting
this guy's trans grooms people felt
similar i have to [ __ ] do the math on
that i would have stepped down because i
don't be the one guy
in a traditionally female role
i i don't know what that means i'm
betting this guy's transgressed people
felt this
similarly i hope you guys understood
what that meant i didn't get that one
sentence
okay and here's where the rant opens up
all right here we go
taking the gloves off there all right a
lot of trans people are
are really pissed by the false and
performative
ally ship the far left has dumped on us
with little work to back their claims up
yeah it's a [ __ ] show that's what i
think so much of that liberal
social justice [ __ ] horseshit is it's
just for you to put on a little
performance on your social media page
and people can be like oh wow you're an
ally here's your little rainbow [ __ ]
emoji
and then you can just go back to living
your life and you're not getting your
hands dirty
um it's like those white people that
marched with black lives matter
as they were live instagramming
themselves
like look at me i have a bandana on i'm
a [ __ ]
revolutionary and then after that they
just went back to their life
got crossfit in the morning we are
identifying
more as independence because we've
experienced hate from the right
and tokenism from the left
oh yeah you get used i mean
which is worse at least i mean i know
the hate if it escalates to violence is
bad at least if somebody's just straight
up
says how they feel about you as opposed
to just using you
anyway i think a lot of your jokes about
trans people are actually more about
performative
cis people i don't know what cis means
who are using trans
issues for votes because they know
we are a very vulnerable group
uh well they kind of do that with
everybody i guess that's the only
positive way
politicians always do that they're
always [ __ ]
looking for some [ __ ] angle for
themselves anyway
but not all they're not all bad there's
got to be some good ones in there trans
people just want to live a normal life
start a family and not be claimed as a
political pawn
i was at my lowest depression before i
started hormones and got my chest
masculine masculine masculinization
procedure what chest did you go with
are they good enough that you can pick
one out because personally speaking uh
you know i would i would go [ __ ]
matthew mcconaughey
um but here's the thing you know what's
funny is if they actually get it down
someday where you could do that all of
these [ __ ]
people who are like anti-trans and all
of that [ __ ] if they find
out that you can actually get a matthew
mcconaughey chest and they're looking at
their [ __ ] man tits they might do it
you know i got the mcconaughey
you know you know what right before they
[ __ ] put the [ __ ] gas on your face
you have headphones
and the last thing you hear is matthew
mcconaughey going all right all right
all right
and you wake up with a chiseled tan
chest
um that'd be [ __ ] hilarious
if i did that as a redhead and my chest
didn't match my the whiteness of my head
then i have to go reverse michael
jackson you know
do a reverse bleaching um anyway let's
not make this about you bill anyway he
says uh
he says i haven't left the house in
weeks i hadn't left the house
in weeks and nearly dropped out of
school since transitioning i'm happy
back on stage volunteering writing music
that's great teaching violin students
running my small business there you go
don't work for somebody else
and i have have met someone special ah
look at you i know i'm from an outside
perspective
being trans i know from an outside
perspective being trans seems crazy
if you knew the thunder and lightning
between my [ __ ] ears i don't think
anybody's crazy
i think it's [ __ ] crazy to uh
go through life and not think that
you're kind of [ __ ] nuts
yourself you know walking around
thinking you have it all figured out i
think that that's [ __ ] crazy i'm not
gonna lie to you like
you know like [ __ ] freaks me out
without a doubt i'm not saying this [ __ ]
but i will tell you when when
bruce became caitlyn there was
definitely you know what the [ __ ] moment
now i'm used to it
but what was weird about that was
if you were like me you weren't for some
reason allowed to have
that what the [ __ ] moment um
which is one of those things that the
left is like
psychotic with it's like you you gotta
you gotta let everybody kind of go
through their emotions as long as
they're not hurting anybody
they're pr you're processing it that's
all right so anyway
this person says i felt the same way
until i realized i would always be angry
be an angry sad person if i had stayed
in the closet
i started listening to your podcast the
same month i came out back in 2017 and
not been offended by the jokes about
trans people
contrary to what the far left or right
want you to think trans folk have
a pretty thick skin and we're no
strangers to having
having to advocate for our rights i've
been doing a lot of work on undoing the
anger i built up over my teenage years
and listening to your show has given me
laughs
when i needed them the most thanks and
go [ __ ] yourself wasn't that great
look at me huh i'm gonna make that whole
[ __ ] thing about me
you know the appeal of me is just really
amazing and you guys i just want to say
as a podcast justice warrior
um all right so if anybody is listening
to this and your kid is gay and they
came out and you disowned him can you
can you not do that to him
that's such a [ __ ] horrible horrible
thing to do to somebody
um it really is it really is it's like
you know
just try to be uh you know
just [ __ ] work your way through it
you know what i mean it's i don't know i
don't i don't get it i don't [ __ ] get
it
that happens to me with one of my kids i
mean it's you
just be who the [ __ ] you are and don't
be a [ __ ] [ __ ] to other people
that's all i ask
can you just do that great all right
you're cool with me okay sign stealing
equals joke stealing
all right hey billy velocity blue balls
uh velocity blue balls oh that's the
ford velocity blue which they're
discontinuing in the f-250 in 2022.
uh just wanted to reach out and see if i
could change your perspective on the
astros sign stealing scandal
because honestly every time you talk
about it i want to punch you in the face
oh do you
i don't give a [ __ ] uh so that being
said let's have some friendly discourse
oh will you let me off the hook
um the way i see it the astros using
electronic video equipment to steal
signs is very similar to comedians
stealing each other's jokes oh my god
this is almost like you took something
that wasn't in my world
and put it in my world by golly i think
it's gonna take two more sentences
and i'll come around to your opinion
all right you really think i'm dumb
don't you
uh more specifically if you apply the
arguments defending the astros to
defending
joke thieves it's easy to see the
hypocrisy
oh is it you sound like gwyneth paltrow
like i'm reading her cookbook it's all
easy okay
imagine me someone who doesn't know jack
[ __ ] about comedy saying
everyone is stealing jokes but people
only hate that comedian because
they got caught that is just like you
saying someone who doesn't know jack
[ __ ] about baseball saying everyone is
stealing signs but people only hate on
the astros
because they got caught um
yeah but for this theory to work every
joke
every comedian would have to be stealing
jokes
they're not okay
that's the difference everyone is
stealing signs in baseball
that's why they have signs
that's why they [ __ ] switch up signs
that's why in football they hold up the
card with the [ __ ] picture of the
eiffel tower
a donut and and [ __ ] uh
michael douglas because people on the
other side are stealing signs
okay contrary to your analogy
is i can do my act in front of 99
of [ __ ] comedians and not have to
worry about getting my jokes stolen
because 99 of comedians do not steal
jokes
but i will continue with your analogy
um and i like how you were ignoring the
fact that the red sox and yankees had
200 million dollar
roided up free agent teams and won a
whole bunch of world series
but evidently that was okay um
and you're gonna get these guys on sign
stealing uh well
that'd be like me saying well that
comedian was funny enough to sell out
msg anyways so it doesn't matter it
doesn't this analogy doesn't work but
i'll continue
i don't understand how you can be so
outspoken against joke stealing
yet still defend cheaters from a
different profession i'm not defending
cheating
i'm not defending cheating what i'm
saying sir
which which i think is hypocritical to
use your word
and when i use this analogy i think it's
just going to be really easy for you to
see
okay is that for people to not look
at teams that field 180 200 million
dollar
teams that had like
future hall of famers on it that they
got from other teams that were doing
steroids
and not question those champions those
those world series rings but then be
like oh these [ __ ]
dirty astros is a joke so here's my
thing
if you're going to call them cheaters
you got to call all of them cheaters
that's my [ __ ] right there because my
thing is i believe that
the same way i feel barry bonds was a
victim of the steroid error
where he was the best guy he was the guy
he was the guy that if anybody was going
gonna break the home run record
he was the guy who was gonna do it and
then these other guys took steroids and
became better than him
and then they say you know the president
bill clinton is calling them
congratulations it's amazing you must be
getting a lot of [ __ ]
right he's calling them so then barry
bonds and no one did anything about it
so barry bonds is like all right
if that's how the game's played [ __ ] it
here's me on roids
and then everybody's like oh barry bonds
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
i think that's ridiculous so i think
it's ridiculous
to [ __ ] ignore what some of those
bigger teams red sox and yankees and all
of those guys did with those
[ __ ] super ridiculous
budgeted [ __ ] teams and the fact that
not only that like not that was so
[ __ ] unfair forget about that they
had the money that they could do that
and then just pay a [ __ ] luxury tax
and and then [ __ ]
nobody gives them [ __ ] nobody says they
were cheating and then the astros come
along they get busted for stealing signs
and they're they're like this secondary
market team
who can't hold on to their [ __ ] stars
because these other behemoths are
vacuuming them up
so they go all right [ __ ] it we got to
steal signs to compete with you and then
they do
and then i'm supposed to feel bad for
the [ __ ] yankees
or if they beat the red sox i'm supposed
to feel bad for us i don't
i don't i would say
that what the astros did is when you go
to jail
you're not supposed to make a shank but
everybody's got one
so in order to survive you got to make
one
okay so going back to your your analogy
there is your analogy is acting like
every comedian steals jokes
they don't your analogy is acting like
everybody in baseball in professional
sports isn't cheating and that's not the
truth
it isn't people get busted all
the [ __ ] time pumping crowd noise in
owners sitting on competition committees
changing the rule of the game
to [ __ ] make it work for them the nfl
the whole [ __ ] nfl
whatever the latest most high-powered
offense is that's working
everybody steals it they break it down
figure out how it works and then
they incorporate it they don't come up
with their own
original offense they do the same things
with defenses i mean i could go [ __ ]
on and on about it
so um nice try with the joke stealing
thing but
uh no pun intended swing and a miss
all right diamonds from cremation
what the [ __ ] dear billy better oneself
my girlfriend recently shared something
with me
that immediately made me think of you
apparently there are companies
that will take the ashes of your loved
ones and convert them into diamonds
i was wondering what your thoughts would
be on this
would be as some women appear to be
turning their dead husbands into jewelry
i immediately thought of my kids it's
like if you can find value in my [ __ ]
burned-up carcass
and it makes your life easy he goes does
it ever end bill
is it ever enough that's so [ __ ]
funny
that's a [ __ ] killer stand-up bit you
should go do that somewhere
anyways oh wait we all steal jokes now
i'm gonna do it
um i'm a long-time listener and hearing
you make efforts to better yourself
over the years has been great big fan
and keep up the great work all right
well you know i hope i'm inspiring you
guys to do the same
um because it is i can't i gotta tell
you i feel the best i've felt
since um i don't know in my adult life
that i actually
finally for the first time i'm starting
to have control over this thing
that was really embarrassing to me and
really hurt people around me which is my
anger
and um
it's funny if you go to therapy and you
really get to the root and you really
just [ __ ]
let it all go and figure out why you're
angry
all of a sudden you look back on i don't
know however long you've been angry
you'd be like that's why i did this this
is why i did that oh i did this what a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that's why i drank the way i drank all
of this [ __ ] it's like the end of a
[ __ ] movie
uh more like a streaming series where
they you find out who [ __ ] did what
right
so um it's been a great thing for me and
it's been an even better thing for the
people around me so
uh yeah that's it all right people and
with that go [ __ ] yourselves and i will
check in on you on thursday